okay hey everyone it's Michael BOS and
welcome to the orderflows market
analysis for Wednesday June 21st 2017
now today the uh existing home sales
actually came out stronger than expected
hinting that there might be a bounce
higher in the housing sector and ending
a streak of bad news on the economy in
general I mean you know if you're
getting um existing home sales uh coming
out strong I I think that's a good sign
for the economy it's not necessarily new
home sales you know new home sales I
think you know it covers a lot of
vacation home second home but new
existing home sales you know people
buying their homes for the first time I
think that's a strong sign stocks were
kind of mixed Dow was down
0.3% and NASDAQ though did get a boost
NASDAQ was up 0.7% Trump was talking
about uh loosening regulations on the
Pharmaceuticals biotechnology uh sectors
so biotechnology stocks rose on the
NASDAQ oil oil was the big uh loser
again it was down another dollar uh we
got down to 4250 despite another draw in
the weekly inventory and and talk of
OPEC um you know arguing over production
Cuts so this is the lowest Futures price
that crude oil has seen since February
of last year so you know it's summer you
got low oil prices you know if you're an
American that's uh that's what you want
no one wants to be flying on United or
some of these other airlines that are
having lots of issues my gosh every week
there's another story about you know
Airlines now I saw a story about you
know people were were on a flight United
flight and you know just getting tossed
around like right EG dolls in the flight
with due to the turbulence um I mean you
know granted it's not United's fault but
still um you know it's just a lot of bad
press recently for these Airlines and
you know so people I know a lot of
people just you know if I can't drive
there you know in the United States if I
can't drive there that I'm not going
there is is their attitude um I mean
granted if you want to travel overseas
you got to fly but uh you know just you
know the the airline industry is just
taking a beating with a lot of bad press
these days
so anyway um let's uh get through the
disclaimer this presentation is for
educational and informational purposes
only should not be considered a
solicitation to buy or sell a Futures
Contract or make any of the type of
investment decision Futures training
contains substantial risk and it's not
for every investor an investor
potentially lose all or more than the
initial investment risk capital is money
that could be lost without shepher ising
one's Financial Security or lifestyle
only risk Capital should be used for
trading and only those with sufficient
risk Capital should consider trading
past performance is not necessarily
indicative of future results you know I
I I go through this disclaimer but I
could really I could tell you stories of
um you know what what people I know have
done you know I knew somebody that took
out a second mortgage on their house
didn't tell their wife second mortgage
for 20,000 and you know went down to a
trading arcade this is about uh 15 years
ago and you know I want to start trading
and you know within the first couple
days lost about $6,000 or was it $ 8,000
I can't remember and you know said screw
this I don't want to risk my my family
you know their um you know their house
and and my kids' future and just gave up
trading went went uh became a
broker and so again you know trading is
is not necessarily for everybody and
again you know most importantly don't
risk money you can't afford to lose you
know I mean you you don't want to break
up your family you don't want to lose
your house or anything like that but you
know
if if you want to take your trading to
the next level I I do believe order flow
is the way to go you know it's going to
teach you how to read the
market so the tools used in this
presentation are going to be the
orderflows trader software which is the
volume footprint chart and I talk a lot
about the Delta scalper you know it's an
indicator that reads the Delta reads the
shifts in supply and demand you know as
it's happening in real time now the
First Market I'll talk about was uh is
is not was is the bonds you know bonds
had been uh this morning kind of
quiet you know we we had made this uh
big pushed down here around starting
around 4: in the morning during the
European
session yeah you got a Divergence up
there on the high you very tight range
though you're talking about uh was that
05 up to 19 and we went from a high to a
low in three bars this is a four range
chart all negative Delta most of this
morning you know from 4 in the morning
onwards until you got to about um you
know 8:00 you started seeing some signs
of some buying coming in you got this
low here at 7 39 point of control near
the bottom of the bar but again you know
I'd prefer it right on the
bottom still have negative Delta which
sort of tells me there's still some
selling pressure left in this market and
what happens is the market just proceeds
to go sideways over the next uh two
hours more or less 930 you got this one
bar very interesting point of control
right on boom right on the bottom you
have a bullish ratio you got a imbalance
right there on the bottom as well and I
remember this was during the room I was
telling everybody in the room to me this
bar is very bullish I don't like that
it's just sort of coming on this area of
sideways activity I Would Love This Bar
if it happened here at 739 where you get
point of control right on the bottom you
get um an imbalance right on the bottom
you get the
uh ratio as well right on the bottom I I
just find it a bit stronger um for more
an immediate move but you know you can
only do you can only React to what the
market is is giving you in this case it
gave it to you here you know after all
the sideways action so you know I know
when I see this I know that there's
support down here there's there's active
buying down here that's why you have
this imbalance you got a lot of people
selling it to this low here you've got a
big passive buyer buyers down here
supporting this market and you know you
got a you got the ratio obviously the
point of control in the bar is right
there did go offer it did go offer it
didn't trade anything below this low and
it rallied back up this bar turned up I
remember telling every said to me this
is a a bullish bar and what happens in
the next bar Delta scalper also comes in
and gives you a buy it's telling you hey
you know this Market is now shifting to
a demand driven market and it just
starts rallying boom boom boom I wanted
to get past this 08 level which is um
one tick above 07 is the opening price
and you know when you have a sideways
day you know a market that's not going
anywhere just spinning its Wheels you
tend to rotate around the opening price
and you know we I don't say in this case
we were you know when I show you the&
it's more evident but in this case you
know we just sort of came back up there
it's always going to be a level when you
spend a lot of time below the opening
price when you come back up towards it
you know can you get past it or you just
going to hang around
it and what happens is we get past it
and rally sell off right back down to it
get down below
it come right back up towards
it hang around it then we start moving
you know if if I feel if this if this
bar had happened back here I think the
move up would have been a lot um
straighter a lot smoother up but in this
case it you know I said it it came after
all the sideways action and I think you
know we just sort of hung around the
opening price rotate around that before
making that move back up towards the
highs we got up within the tick of the
high here high of the day um you got a
single print you got a ratio the market
sold off and right now in the night
session we are just sort of hanging
around going
sideways okay so the next market I'll
talk about is the 5 years now every day
I come into this I do these recordings
and and I say look for a ratio and a
Divergence the ratio is is a blue number
above a red bar or you know if it was a
if it was going to be a uh green bar
would be below and Divergence is this
Arrow here which tells you you you have
negative Delta on a high or positive
Delta on a low so you got Divergence and
a ratio and what happens you sell off
from your highs down into lows and new
lows now you got down here this was
interesting again this is something I
was discussing in the room today um you
got down to 08 and you put in a crap
load of
volume
um you know at this time is 16,000 you
know this is about 25,000 here another
uh 8,000 here another 5,000 there so you
put in you know about 30,000 40,000 Lots
right in here just in these three bars
right at 08 and to me that that's a sign
okay that's a sign that there's there's
obviously interested to transact at that
level so what I'm going to be watching
over the next couple bars are we going
to stay above it or below it next bar
came in obviously down below it and then
this bar here at 9:00 we rally back up
to 08 can't get past it still a lot of
sellers up there 5,850 trade market
sells off again you know so if if you
know this is what to me this would be a
lowrisk entry you you test that level
you get short just you know right around
there um you know I don't think you can
get in at 08 but you know at 8 at 7 and3
3/4 easily and you know the market sold
off again it sold all the way down to 6
and A4 came back up tested it again
didn't get back down to the low got down
to 6 and2 and then you know 10:00 we
started coming back up this was the time
where Bonds were starting to Rally here
um we hit this we came back up to 07 and
3/4 now again I'm just going to watch
what was going to happen if we hit 08
boom you hit 08 Bing balance comes you
know buying a balance this time is
enough to get past it okay goes bid
rallies all the way up to uh
9 and 3/4 I I remember saying you know
if we get past this 08 level you know we
could probably rally up just past this I
was looking more around 9 and a half
past this 9 level which was the opening
price we do we hit it and then we start
coming back off again and rotating
around the opening price but now look
what ' 08 which is here um might be
easier if I put the crosshairs 08 is
this level here okay so now what was
your resistance is acting as your
support and now that we're clearly above
it you know it just it's just beautiful
um the way it's acting as support there
now you know we're into the evening
session we're we're still higher so you
know that that's a good sign you know
bonds was you know showing a bearish
ratio and you know this imbalance on the
top so it's kind of bearish well 5 years
look a little bit uh A Little Bit
Stronger actually but I said you know
we're talking only we're only in one bar
since we've reopened so a very tight
range um you know I can't really make
any decent uh decision off of one bar in
U in the five
years now uh just really quick you know
buns again you know since we're on
interest rates again you know I I I talk
about it every single day ratio 81.3
it's blue number right this is a bullish
ratio 05 a black number is just your
normal order flow you know 1.6
1967 and you have a Divergence as well
you got the negative Delta on the high
and what happens is is you sell off from
the 25 26 area down to um you know the 0
0607 area I mean you did go lower a bit
later but again I find this bar to be
kind of bullish you do start rallying
you get the next bar up and then you run
into a bearish number here and then you
know this dogee bar and I find this this
type of Delta candle just looking at the
Delta right you know if if you're not
looking at the candle what you have is
very strong positive Delta 1541 and it
ends up at min-2 actually gets down to-
158 but you know more importantly it
ends up at-2 which is kind of neutral so
you had very strong positive Delta in
the bar yet the bar Delta finished
neutral finished at min-2 which is also
a bearish signal so you got bearish
signal there bearish signal here and you
know the market did uh didn't start
trading lower here here went down to the
lows down into new lows this time you
got so you know up here you know at at
24 at this High 29 rather you got the
ratio you got the Divergence next bar
you got the Delta scalper given a sell
signal and you know what what else can I
tell you it sold off then you got down
to this low around
730 ratio 879 you know it's a blue
number
Divergence Delta scalper as well price
projector as well and you know
everything's telling you the Market's
going to Rally what does it do it puts
in this half-hearted rally um you know
once it starts going sideways when it
follows up with you know you got a green
bar right you got everything telling you
to buy and what happens next bar is red
you know there's no ratio though so
again it's not the end of the world but
really what you're looking for is the
move to happen you're not looking for
the move to go sideways like this and
then come up um you know honestly you
know if when you're looking at this red
bar then you got a green bar then a red
bar then another green bar Market is
telling you it's going sideways it's
alternating it's just hanging around
here since 7:34 up to 8:00 it hasn't
done anything so you know at what point
are you going to get out of the trade
you're going to wait for it to make its
move or you just going to cut it and
just you know wait for something better
to happen I it does put in a little bit
of rally up to
95 and then sells off but you know
that's an hour later you know at what
point are you going to say this trade's
not paying off and get out of it you
know the longer you're in a trade that's
going nowhere the less effective it's
going to be you know don't think think
that you're in this trade because hey I
got a ratio I've got Divergence I've got
Delta scalper and an hour later the
Market's not moved and you're still in
the trade you should be out of the trade
don't stay in the trade that long where
it's not paying you you know it's really
at that point an hour later the reason
for taking the trade in in my opinion is
already um disappeared you know it
should make its move and it should make
its move quickly like like you saw here
on this move lower at 5:00 you know this
is how you want it you want it to happen
and you want it to happen fast 5:00 by
6:00 yeah it's an hour later I
mean but you know you're not taking any
heat you know it's not going sideways
it's not giving you um you know a a
green bar it's not rallying back up then
coming off and rally back up it's making
its move that it's making the move the
way it should you know so you could
assess this you know you're getting
short an hour later yeah it's made its
move it's red bars is going in the
direction whereas on this one you you're
getting long and it's giving you
conflicting signals you know you should
be looking at Green bars here not red
then green then red then green like that
uh but anyway you know it comes back
down into uh new lows a little bit later
you got the ratio sorry you got the
Divergence no ratio in this bar it's
just 1.5 just your normal number next
bar is you have the ratio does rally up
a little bit um comes back down you hit
the low again ratio with Divergence then
this is the move that you're looking for
um you know you didn't get it here it
just came right back again this wouldn't
have stopped you out um you know your
stop would be below this low of the
Divergence but you know more importantly
you got the racio and Divergence again
so you know say you didn't take this
trade or you got out of this trade for
whatever reason you know this red bar
then a doge and then a red bar you know
probably get out also um rather than
letting it come stop me out but again
it's telling me hey you know what it's
giving me another entry here and now
this time it makes the move it makes the
move from you know 86 all the way up to
01 before it starts uh coming off and
later closing around 94 so you know
there was some decent trades there in in
the Buns um you know if you just follow
that one thing I tell you ratios and
Divergence um before I get to the snps
uh let's talk
about give me a sec here
um crude uh take a look at crude again
you know crude was
crude you had the inventory numbers
today but you know there's something
again I just want to talk about you know
being in a trade
for a long
time but anyway before I do again you
know this is something I I talk I've
talked about before you know this is a I
don't say a nugget you know it's not
something
I've I discovered but is actually you
know somebody else had just discovered
it and and I learned it is you know when
you get when you hit a double top or
double bot bottom and you get less
volume the second time it's important
okay so first time you know here we got
this High 29 lot trade then 15 lot trade
you know it's it's telling me you know
the buying the second time around is
lesser right you know everyone always
talks about um I'm a price action Trader
I'm a price action Trader you know and
they're looking at just a normal bar
chart and you know if you're just
looking at a normal bar chart you see a
double top here in price action oh you
should be selling it you know even
though then later it makes a new high
but if you're looking at order flow
right you can see well it traded 29
now even you know this time as you get
up here near the top it's got a lot less
volume 29 the next time is 15 even on on
the offer side 140 142 in this part 299
51 409 120 150 even on the on the bid
side um 26 versus 130 105 versus 300 158
versus 256 so on this move back up you
got a lot less volume going through up
here so it's telling me the buying is
drying up and you know to me that that's
important information right people say
oh you don't need volume in your
analysis just look at Price well that's
that's that's wrong you know you have to
look at the volume that's trading you
know it's
it's like you
know my my parents like to watch this
show the pickers and you know I used to
I watch it too I admit but you know my
mom blessed her heart will see this guy
Mike and Frank and they'll they'll buy
something right they'll buy something
off some old farmer uh you know Frank
always likes to uh lowball the guy but
then you know you see later in in the
show they'll say okay yeah they bought
this for you know
$350 and they put a value on it of 750
so it looks like oh my oh they doubled
their money well not really you know the
the amount of people out there that want
to buy you know this beat up old Mobile
Oil sign is it's a very small number and
you know once you sell it to somebody
say you sell it at you know $750
it's not like you get an unlimited
supply of those signs and you'll sell
them for the same price you know you get
more signs well you know you're buying
the people that want to buy it are are
starting to dry up because you know
they've they've already bought it you
know they've they've got their fill and
they don't need it anymore so you know
so now you're you're people you selling
it for 750 to you know maybe a couple
people they bought them now you get some
more signs of thinking hey you know you
think 750 is a pop but no it's not
because now you got more signs but you
got less people that want to buy it
right and so you know it just becomes
worth less so even though you still pay
350 for it now instead of selling them
for $750 you're selling them for 700
then 650 then 600 and you know that's
how price drops when you know people
lose interest in buying it you know
either because one they've already
bought it or two you know there's just
not enough buyers when there's not
enough buyers prices just drop until you
know all of a sudden Mike and Frank can
sell their beat up old gasoline sign to
people and still make a profit but
anyway um you know point is you know
when you hit a double top or double
bottom you know watch the volume is it
less if it's less the second time around
it's usually a good sign that you know
the Market's going to hold at that that
high level is going to hold and it's
going to make a reaction it's going to
react off it and sell
off um but anyway U what I want to talk
about here is 840 you know here you get
the Delta scoper giving you a buy off
the swing
low and you know it's 840 okay the
market just goes sideways over the next
four bars five bars it's 918 and you're
about breaking even on the trade what
are you going to do you got a number
coming out um I I wouldn't stand for the
number you know I I would say stand for
it in the sense of what I mean to stand
you know with a position up on exposed
while the number comes out but again you
know you're looking for the move to
happen it's not happening and you know
at some point you got to say okay this
trade is not paying me I mean does it
work yeah eventually it does 9:30 the
number comes out Market pops up and you
know people will say well the delta
scalper look at that had a nice trade
you could have got in here at uh 54 and
got out at uh you know 44 bucks or
something like that but no um you know
at some some
point you shouldn't really be trying to
play a number when you're day trading
but you know again you know looking for
the move to happen it's not you get red
green bar here then dogee then red then
green again okay this is a sign that
maybe maybe it can but you know honestly
you should just be by the time you get
to this bar you should just be looking
to break even on this trade eventually
it does pop up and you know becomes a
nice big winner but honestly you know if
the number came out the opposite
direction and you're long here at
4360 next thing you know is trading 43
bucks and you know you're on the wrong
side of History so again you know don't
don't try to play the number when you
know you're not an economist you're not
out there um in the field so to speak so
anyway the market does rally off the
number
um again you hit this High Delta scalper
right here price rejector but again
you're not going to be trading that by
the time you get in you know the market
well in this case the market is probably
about 10 or 15 cents
lower um you know later it did uh you
know it still hasn't calmed down 937 you
know 10:00 yeah 10:00 probably You' say
it slowed down you got Delta scalper
there sold off um again hits the opening
price it sort of rotates around and you
know then you know later in the day
11:30 just starts selling off selling
off here you
got a ratio and a Divergence in next bar
you got the ratio price re uh Delta
scaler and this one fails doesn't work
out it just comes right back on you
pretty quick bunch of failed divergences
here um more selling more selling more
selling um yeah this bar here again you
know it's Market's moving pretty quick
at this time but um you know again I I
love these green bars with point of
controls near the bottom or red bars
with Point controls near the
top you know like like in this case here
at 1212 you know this is the type of bar
I like it's just telling me there's some
support in this market down here on this
low and you do get a bounce
higher just like I showed you in the
bonds now the other so we'll take a look
now at
um let's talk about soybeans you know I
mean like to mix it up I mean beans are
a great Market to trade you know part of
that is I the reason I think that is cuz
I know that um but you know all those
times I spent a lot of time trading
grains and so what do you got here 8:30
is the
reopen start rallying up towards their
High boom Delta scalper up here near the
high giving a nice sell Market sells off
into new lows keeps going lower lower
lower lower lower low lower get down to
this low you don't have a ratio you like
you don't have a Divergence not really
necessarily a reason to be buying down
here Delta scalper giving a sell but
it's a sell near the low and it's coming
you know you got a bullish ratio Delta
scalper bearish ratio bullish ratio
bearish ratio it's kind of a market
that's just mixed at this point
eventually the market does sell off um
you know it hits this low just a but
look at this Delta very strong negative
351 667 649 900 um
get up here Red Bar point of control
right at the top I do like that you know
I again I like this also um
unfortunately it's sort of coming in
this
area you know I'm always hesitant when I
get a bearish ratio bullish ratio when I
start seeing you know sort of
alternating ratios like this to me it's
a sign of a market going sideways um I I
sort of like you know things like this
you know Market comes up starts coming
off but again you know I I like that but
I prefer this bar to pee over here I
like the point of control right at the
top telling me to stop this move but
then you know the market sells off
you're coming up on 1:00 again you
shouldn't be TR around in the
grains um going into the
close um so we do sell off hit this low
this one has a ratio no Divergence here
you got a r no ratio no Divergence um
we've reopened and we're trading around
918 right now all right so
snps if I can find my SPO chart
all right that's some PS it was a very
interesting morning kind of boring
actually I I did kind of expect the
market to be relatively boring um you
know
whenever whenever um in the morning when
I start trading you there's some things
I always look at okay I always like to
look at a daily
chart um just sort of see you know what
happened I mean I I I do have my charts
open so I know what happened overnight
but you know try and get a better
perspective of what's going on in the
market so Monday um
what day was this the 19th I'm losing
track of days here
Monday and you had this big update right
you had big update on Monday what
happened on Tuesday no follow through
you didn't take out the high you didn't
go up there instead you got a red
bar and then you're coming into
Wednesday morning and at the you know
coming into Wednesday you yeah you push
lower right you push down to 29 and
change something like that I think it
was 28 3/4s but you know you're just
sort of around break even in the morning
you know actually around 700 in the
morning 8:30 you're up here near your
highs of the day but you you saw the
follow through right just like you
didn't see the follow through when you
reopened on Tuesday night you didn't get
the follow through after this big day up
I mean when you have a big day up you
know what you want to see is follow
through in the next session just like
you saw it here you know that's what you
want um yeah this one you you saw it but
by the time you came into the morning
you're you're you know you're kind of
changed and you know so Monday you had
the big update Tuesday no follow through
well Wednesday you're coming into the
day you just you're you're well below
the previous day's close
and I want to say well below but you
know you
had hang on you're you know basically
you're you're following through on the
negative side you didn't follow through
on the positive side up here you're
following through on the negative side
so you know I had that in mind that you
know yeah maybe we could push lower I
would have likeed to see
us trade higher but you know if we trade
higher we're just going to trade into
the value area from the day
before so anyway um you came in here
Cash open you made a new high you got a
ratio you got a Divergence okay all
systems go what happens the market
proceeds to go sideways on you and just
hangs around the opening price again you
on a directionless day you tend to
rotate around the opening price and you
do okay then what happens 10:00 just for
10 you poke higher okay new high no
ratios 21 price rejector
yeah um you got positive Delta okay so
you got a range extension up you know
you made new highs after you know your
initial balance so to speak you made new
Highs at this point I'm already thinking
you know the market starts sun off ratio
ratio you're just got through your
opening price and again I remember
watching the volume profile and telling
everyone in the room you know at the
time you didn't have this information
you didn't have all this volume down
here at this time this was what the
profile looked like and down here very
very thin and I remember I said if we
get past this 33
area down in here where it had thin
volume I expect the market to drop down
to new lows I did expect us to make new
lows you know we got you know because
that's what happens you know on a day
that's dominated by daytime frame
Traders traders that just trade during
the day you know they'll test the high
and they'll test the low and you'll just
rally back up into the value area um you
know profile Traders these are the days
that they live for you get up above the
value area how you sell the out of
it and for a move back down into value
area you get down below you make new uh
you get down below the value area make
new lows you buy the out of it and
rally back up and that's what they do I
sound like in The Terminator that's what
he does but that's what Val volume
that's what the profile Traders do is
they recognize where value is you get
above it you sell it get below it you
buy it you do that also everybody does
that you go to the grocery store you
know there things you're going to be
buying if it's cheaper sometimes you buy
more you know my wife likes cakes and
when the store has a sale two for one I
don't need six cakes in the
house for a week but you know when it's
on sale I buy you know buy three you
know so I get another three and I just
stick them in the freezer so um you know
we we all do it in in some in some form
you know when things are value you know
when when things are undervalued you
know we tend to buy more of
it so you what happens the market sells
off we get down to 30 um I say about 30
and half 30 and 3/4 rally back up here
and then make the move down um but again
you know that that's what I was
expecting and then you know look for the
profile Traders for find a reason be
buying to come back up and what happens
as it does it rallies back up in here
and right now we're you know what time
is it it's about
7 7:30 Chicago time um we got a raal
Divergence we'll see how this one plays
out later but um again you know this the
market did what
it does on these normal trading days you
know it get above value sells off back
into the value area gets below value
rallies back up towards the value area
and at the end of the day you end up
with this kind of normal distribution
right
here um talk about the Yen I didn't talk
about currencies yet but um I'll talk
about the Yen really quick there were
some interesting things I saw on the Yen
this
morning um
if I could find
it oh about aie I'll talk about Yen I'll
talk about Aussie in
second so can you know can you I show
you these charts they look alike for
God's sakes but they're different okay
you got
your ratio and your Divergence at this
High Delta scalper as well you know at
the 90 38 and what do you do you get the
red bar Red Bar Red Bar it just makes
its move nicely you know that's what you
want right Delta scalper price reject uh
Delta scalper ratio Divergence right up
there on that high that's that's what
you
want comes down here Delta scalper but
it's a red candle so you shouldn't
really be interested in taking it you
know if you're getting long you know you
want the candle to be green not red um
then you come down you actually make new
lows honestly when it got down into this
area I've remember telling people you
know this is probably the area should
you would have been maybe thinking of
taking some off but again it's still you
got negative Delta so it doesn't
necessarily mean that you know the move
is
over and you get down new lows new lows
new lows ratio with Divergence so you
went for your ratio with Divergence on
your high to a ratio with Divergence on
the
low and what happens the next bar is
green and then red okay so what's the
market telling you it's telling you you
know you're not making that straight up
move you know just as you made the
straight move down you know it's kind of
I'll say stumbling but you know it's not
making the move that you want it to make
and next bar is green goes back up so
you got green red green next bar red at
this point you should be thinking
you know maybe this trade's not going to
be working
out next bar red into the new lows so
again if you don't pick it up here that
it's not working out you're going to get
stopped out here again it's not the end
of the world that you get stopped out on
a trade just wait for the next trade
make new
lows um come start down making new lows
here you know failed Divergence failed
Divergence um a new low here no
Divergence then you start rallying back
up and you get up here swing High Delta
scalper giv a sell next bar bearish
ratio you know you got that imbalance up
there on the high you got some trap
Traders up here near this high and you
sell off again Delta scop are given a
buy what happens is you rally back up
you know this is you know when you have
the Delta scalper right or any trade you
know what you want to see you want the
market to move you want it to move in
your favor quickly and if it's not you
know it's probably not going to be very
effective um so here Delta scalper Red
Bar Red Bar you know this is how you
like it here you got Delta scalper bu
but then you got a red bar with the
bearish ratio it's not encouraging sign
but then the next bar comes right back
up point of control is right at the same
level which is good you know even if
this point of control was higher that
would also be a good
sign um so again you know if you're in
this trade in this bar you're thinking
what am I doing but it's nice that
it came back really quick here that next
bar is up up up up um you know keeps
going up
here and then you know right now then we
closed on the day around uh
9012 and really quick Aussie dollar I
don't really talk about Aussie dollar
it's you know it's one of these kind you
know
trades I say slowly but you know it's
not as volatile as say the in generally
it's not as Vol say the Yen or euro
currency but you know it's it's
interesting you know you've got this
green bar here negative Delta on the
low it do rally up price uh Delta
scalper here Delta surge here you sell
off you know you had the
um again you know on the these lows you
get imbalance here you get an imbalance
here this time you got the you know it's
not a a bullish ratio it's very close
it's 7 to I use 7 actually you have a
Divergence you got um an imbalance there
on the low next bar dog strong positive
Delta again this is still on um
Wednesday's trade date Delta scop we
given the Buy Signal and right now in
the Asian session we are up a little bit
not much but again it's this this a
market that just sort of Lopes a long
often times um unless some data comes
out in in Australia but is it a good
Market to trade I mean it's $10 a tick
it's kind of a little bit different I
believe than the rest of the currencies
but um I don't know you mean sometimes
you get really nice moves in it and
sometimes it just you know it's just
kind of a boring Market to
trade but again it's up to you um but
again you I I know some people are
interested it there's some guys in
Australia that trade with these
indicators um I don't if they're
interested in traing the Aussie dollars
you know most of the people I know that
live overseas just stick with Minis and
crude but um you it's just interesting
to look at you you know order flow I
mean I showed you soybeans I showed you
Aussie dollar all these different
currencies you know I'm looking at the
same things basically it's not like you
know each market has got something
different you know pretty much
everything I'm looking at the same
things in in every
market so uh thanks for watching this
video if you want to learn more about
trading
with orderflow visit my website
orderflows
docomo it by clicking on the Subscribe
button below and um you know if you're
interested in Deltas scalper visit
Deltas scaler.com um I'm probably going
to stop selling it and I'm going to sort
of merge it in the orderflows trader and
and Jack say jack up the price but um
you know raise the price cuz I do got to
pay the programmer for he gets a cut of
everything as well so um thanks everyone
and I hope the see you on the inside
bye-bye